SHALINI AGARWAL: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Actions in the inbox
powered by schemas.
I'm Shalini Agarwal.
This is Claudio Cherubino.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Hi.
SHALINI AGARWAL: And we are
really excited to be here
today to tell you about a cool
new feature that we are
launching in Gmail.
So let's start with
a show of hands.
How many of you send emails
to your users
asking them to do something?
All right.
How many of you care if your
users actually do what you ask
them to do?
Perfect.
OK, so then you know that
today we have a problem.
Email is not efficient.
It's like a scavenger hunt
trying to do anything.
For every email that you send
your users, they have to read
the email, figure out what they
need to do, open a bunch
of tabs, decide to take action,
and then do it.
It's a lot of steps,
and each email
takes too long to process.
That's even if the user decides
to open the email in
the first place.
So let's go ahead and see this
in efficiency in action.
How many steps do you think it
takes to rate and review a
restaurant?
First, you get the email.
Second, you click on it, you
read it, and you decide that
you're going to click
on a link.
Third, you click on the link.
You open the tab and you
wait for it to load.
Fourth, if you remember your
login information,
you enter it here.
And fifth, you do what you
wanted to do in the first
place, which is rate and review
the restaurant, and
click Submit.
And then sixth, you
close the tab.
And if you remember, you go back
to your inbox to process
the next email.
It's a very cumbersome process,
and users get lost
along the way.
This inefficiency is only
made worse by the
sheer volume of email.
As a product manager at Google,
I get a lot of email.
In fact, I counted.
And in the last week alone,
I received 2,124 emails.
During this session alone,
over 100 million
emails will be sent.
Your users are out there doing
this scavenger hunt right now.
Between email inefficiency and
email volume, it's no wonder
that a lot of emails go
unanswered or unopened.
You are probably tracking
your own stats and see
some of that today.
But today, we are introducing
a solution.
We're adding actions to the
inbox, making email smarter.
Now, your users can get the gist
of what you're trying to
tell them and take action
without ever leaving the
inbox, without even
opening email.
So remember the six-step process
that we talked about?
Let's see what that looks like
with actions in the inbox.
With actions in the inbox, we're
taking that six-step
process and turning it
into just two steps.
We'll take a look at
it with a demo.
Last night, I ordered food
from India Clay Oven via
Seamless web.
Today, Seamless has sent me an
email asking me to rate my
experience.
Seamless have added actions
to their email.
So I see the email, Seamless,
asking me how
was India Clay Oven?
And I get this handy button
on the right-hand
side that says Review.
I click on it, and I get this
beautiful overlay that gives
me the key information
I need--
India Clay Oven via Seamless,
a beautiful picture from the
restaurant, and a quick
rating widget.
So I can go ahead and
click it five
stars and enter a comment.
Spicetastic.
Will definitely be back.
Definitely order again.
And I hit Post Review.
On the back end, Gmail has now
sent this rating to Seamless,
and I'm done.
That's it.
[APPLAUSE]
SHALINI AGARWAL: Two steps.
Now, that's efficient.
Let's go back.
So we've enabled actions
in the inbox through
the power of schemas.
You guys already know
about schemas.
They're an important part
of the web today.
You add markup to your websites
to improve your
search results.
Now, you can add markup to your
emails to enable these
actions directly from
the inbox and
deliver them to Gmail.
You can deliver a slice
of your app to
Gmail starting today.
A product with hundreds
of millions of users.
Over the coming weeks, we'll be
rolling out four different
kinds of actions.
We've already talked about rate
and review, and now we'll
talk about the one-click action,
the RSVP action, and
the goto action.
And, of course, we'll
do it through demos.
So as you can see here, I've
gotten an email from Google
Offers about an offer from
American Apparel.
Because they've added schema
to their emails, I get this
one-click button that
says Get Offer.
Because I shop at American
Apparel all the time, I'll go
ahead and click the offer.
One click, without
ever leaving the
inbox, I saved the offer.
Now, let's go over to
offers.google.com, reload the
tab, and there it is.
I didn't even have to open an
email and I've been able to
save my offer.
Now, one-click buttons are my
favorite action because they
enable the widest variety
of use cases.
So let's look at a second demo
of the one-click action.
I use a service called Esna to
manage my communications.
And they've sent me this email
telling me that I have missed
a call from Claudio.
And because now seems like a
good enough time as any to
call him back, I'll click
this one-click
button that says Dial.
Now, on the back end, what's
happening is that Gmail has
notified Esna that I want
to initiate the call.
[PHONE RINGING]
SHALINI AGARWAL: And they've
initiated the call between
Claudio and myself.
As you can see, my
phone is ringing.
I'll Go ahead and pick it up.
I don't know if Claudio's
going to pick it up.
We'll find out.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Probably not.
SHALINI AGARWAL: So he'll be
receiving a call any minute
now that I've picked it up.
[PHONE RINGING]
SHALINI AGARWAL: And
there we go.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Woo.
[APPLAUSE]
SHALINI AGARWAL: All right.
One click directly
from the inbox.
The third type of action
is the RSVP action.
As you can see here, Clarence
has invited me to a taco
night, which is my favorite
type of event.
Because Calendar has added
actions to the inbox with some
markup, I get this RSVP button
right here, similar to rate
and review.
When I click on it, I get the
overlay showing me the most
important information.
The fact that it's a taco night
hosted by Google Calendar.
It's on Tuesday at 7:00 PM.
It's at Tortilla Heights, and
one person's already going.
I don't miss a taco night.
So, of course, I'm
going to say yes.
And there it is.
I'm done.
Let's go over to Google Calendar
and make sure that my
response was recorded.
Here it is, Taco Night.
I click on it and there it is.
Yes, I'm going.
The fourth and final type of
action is the goto action.
The goto action is reserved for
the most complex type of
actions, which really
cannot be handled
from within the inbox.
So flight check-in, as you can
see here, the last email from
Oceanic Airlines, I get a button
on the right-hand side.
They've used the goto action.
When I click on this button,
it'll take me to a deep link
on their website to check-in,
where I can select my seat.
I can tell them how many
bags I'm bringing.
And whatever security
questions I
might have to answer.
And that's it.
Those are the four
types of actions.
However, sometimes no
action is required.
Sometimes your users just need
key information from you.
So for these situations,
we've added
structured interactive cards.
The first one that we're
adding is for flight.
So when users get flight
confirmation email, check-in
reminders, or updates, they get
this beautiful card at the
top of their email that gives
them the airport details, the
flight details, their connection
times, as well as a
real-time layer on top of that
telling them if their flight
is on-time, delayed, or--
hopefully not-- canceled.
Flight is only the first
card we're adding.
Over time, we'll add
more cards, such
as events and hotels.
So by adding schema to your
emails, you can enable these
actions and cards in Gmail.
However, you can also enable
experiences for your users
across Google.
When your users use Google Now
or Google Search, they will
get the information that you
send them at the most useful
time and place.
I'll leave you with
one last thought.
This is a developer platform,
and the power of it really
comes in how you decide
to use it.
We'll be rolling out these
features over the next few
weeks and be adding
more over time.
Now, I'll hand it over
to Claudio to tell
you how it all works.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Thanks, Shalini.
[APPLAUSE]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Well, thank you.
I haven't done anything yet.
So I'm very happy to be here.
I work in the developer
relations team from Google.
And one of the questions that
I always get when talking to
developers like you is, how do
I get my app into Gmail?
It's a common request.
I understand why you want to be
in Gmail, why you want your
app in Gmail.
And today, we're finally
introducing a way
for you to do that.
And what we're introducing
is super simple.
So not only we're giving you
this opportunity, but we're
giving an opportunity in the
easiest possible way.
All it takes is some markup
that you have
to add to your emails.
So you have your emails.
You probably already send
emails to your users.
So you have an HTML email
with your content,
your regular content.
You don't have to touch it.
You don't have to do anything
with the content you're
already sending.
All you have to do is add in
some markup, some extra markup
to the same emails, and
then clients will
render that for you.
So you add some markup at the
top of your email, at the
bottom of your email, in the
middle, somewhere in your
HTML, and clients, like Gmail,
will render it for you.
I say clients like Gmail, and
I will go back to this,
because this is going to
be an open platform.
And Gmail is starting
to launch this
in the coming weeks.
But we expect other clients
to implement
this technology, too.
So what happens when you add
your schema is that we render
it as the corresponding button
or drop down or piece of UI or
card, whatever corresponds
to your markup.
And one important thing to note
there is that the UI is
consistent.
So Gmail will always render an
event reservation, RSVP drop
down with the same
UI, regardless
of who's the sender.
So your user will not be
confused by messy UI or a
piece of interface that do not
really belong to Gmail.
The client controls the
experience, and that's really
important for the user, is not
to be confused, to use this
technology.
So you add the markup.
It's going to be a few lines.
I'm going to show that.
And we will render it.
And the one thing that I just
mentioned is that this is
based on an open platform.
We're building on top of
schema.org, which is a broader
initiative, open initiative for
a vocabulary of entities
that we're building on top of.
So the types we're defining, the
types you will use in your
markup are the same types that
you're already using if you
know about schema.org.
Well, let's show an example.
This is how it looks like.
And I actually have two
different formats, because we
support two different formats
for this markup.
The one on your left is the
standard schema.org migrator.
If you know about schema.org
and semantic web, you've
probably seen this.
You probably implemented this.
You probably added this
to your HTML.
It's pretty easy
to understand.
It's an XML-based language.
Actually, what you do here is
that you add some properties
to your HTML.
And these properties attributes
will tell us what
the item is.
And in this example,
we have an event.
And then what properties
the event has--
the start time, the end time,
location, and so on.
The same thing can
be also expressed
with a different format.
There is also now the
open standard.
It's called JSON [? lt. ?]
It is not XML-based.
It's obviously JSON-based.
And we found that this other
format, this alternative
format is easier to
read for humans.
There are libraries to write
both, so you as a developer
can, probably, easily
write both.
But for a human, the one on the
right is easier to write.
So as you can see, those 10
lines, and the ones on the
right are just easier to read,
tell us that this email is
about an event.
And that event starts at this
date, ends at that date, and
there's also location.
And we will render it as an
event should be rendered.
So we have the markup, different
markup for the four
different types of actions, and
structure data like flights.
I will show you an example
of each of them.
And I would say that
all of them are
shorter than 10 lines.
Well, no more than 20 lines.
So we have four different
types of action.
And we'll see them one by one.
But all of them follow
the same structure.
So you will see that there are
common sections every time I
introduce a new type.
And the sections are,
essentially, three sections in
each markup.
So we usually have a section at
the top that is about the
entity you're defining.
And that is, for instance, in
the example we just saw, to
describe what the event is
or what the flight is.
So the entity you're
talking about.
And that has properties that you
can see from schema.org,
from the vocabulary
we're using.
And after the item definition,
we have our first addition to
the schema, which is actions.
Actions have different types
and have different names.
So if you want to implement the
RSVP action or our review
action, those have
different types.
And you have to specify
that there.
But then, in the third
part, you describe
what the handler is.
The handler is used to tell us
what to do with the action.
So you've seen Gmail sending
requests to you when the user
performs an action.
Those requests will be sent to
a URL, to an end point, to a
servlet, to somewhere
you tell us.
And that is where
you define it.
Let's go on with the
real example.
The first type of action--
I'm going to show you
the markup for--
is one-click action.
This is what Shalini called
her favorite.
Because this is super-flexible.
Gmail renders these one-click
actions as buttons.
When the user clicks on the
button, Gmail will send a
request to your endpoint.
So how this works in the
microdata, in the markup you
see, in this example I'm
showing an email
that is about a movie.
And one action we can perform
with one click
is Add to Your Queue.
So at the top, you
will see some
information about the movie--
movie title, and maybe the cast,
maybe genre, all the
other properties
we want to add.
And then we have the action.
The action in this case
is called Save action.
There will be a list of all the
supported actions in the
docs that we're launching
right now.
So at the end of this talk, I
will give you a link to the
documentation we're launching.
But this action is called
Save action.
You can customize what the
button will look like.
So you can customize the
label for the button.
And we're going to call
it Add to Queue.
And then you define the
action handler.
In this case, what you need to
do is just say, when the user
clicks on a button, I want a
post request sent to my URL.
So you send us this markup.
You set up a servlet that
can handle this request.
When Gmail sends your request
in the background, you will
have to handle the request--
in this case, add the
movie to the queue--
and respond with a standard
HTTP response code.
So if the action is performed
correctly, you respond with a
200 and Gmail will show it
as successfully executed.
If there is an error--
for instance,
the request is invalid--
you respond with a 400.
Standard HTTP response code.
You know about that.
So this is the common
structure--
entity, action, action
handler.
And you will see the same
structure in the second type
of action we are
defining here.
This is RSVP action.
The main difference here is
that Gmail knows that RSVP
actions deserve a special UI,
which is not a button.
But it's, instead, a drop down
with some information about
the entity, which is an event.
And then, buttons for
you to reply.
You, as a developer, can choose,
if you want, yes,
maybe, no, all of them,
just yes and no.
You can customize the look
of this small drop down.
And once that is rendered, the
result is always the same.
Gmail renders it.
The user clicks on one of the
actions, one of the buttons.
Gmail collects the input from
the user, sends that as a post
request to your endpoint with
the parameters you want.
You process it and
respond with the
appropriate response code.
So on your side, we'll still
have to implement some
servlet, some back end
that can handle this.
And then, Gmail will talk
to this directly.
Now that you know two of them,
this is going to be super easy
to understand-- rate
and review.
You saw that in the
first demo.
We showed Seamless, which is
one of our partners, using
this technology to review
restaurants from the inbox.
What you can customize
here is the scale.
And in our case, there was
one to five stars.
And you can also tell us if
you want an optional text
feedback or if you want a
required text feedback.
It's up to you.
Some companies need that, some
websites need both a text
comment and a rating.
Some others do not.
Of course, the easier it is
for your users, the more
responses you will get.
So that's basically it.
You configure it, and
then-- same thing.
You get a request from Gmail.
You respond to it,
and that's it.
And we render the response.
The only action type that is
slightly different is the goto
link, goto action.
This is rendered as a
button with a link.
We talked about check-in.
Check-in is not an action
that can be performed
easily in the inbox.
You have to select seats,
buy upgrades,
select food, meal, whatever.
You have to do many steps.
And that doesn't really apply
to inside your inbox.
So we can take you directly
to the page
where you can do that.
Another example--
and we have it here--
is a request for you to
sign some documents.
The documents are not
sent in the email.
You can click on the link and
be brought to the page where
you can sign the documents.
So we strongly recommend you
to use and implement the
in-app actions, like RSVP,
review, or one-click action.
Because with those, users do not
have to leave the inbox.
For all other cases, you can use
a goto action if that is
the best user experience
for your user.
Of course, we plan to
add more actions.
And we want to listen from you
about what you think might be
useful to add.
So we'll talk about it later,
but we want to know what you
plan to do with this.
So we show all the four
types of actions.
The other thing we're launching
is structured data
for specific items.
And we talked about flights.
A flight is easy to understand
piece of structured data.
A flight has some specific
properties.
So we know about those
We know that a flight
has a departure
airport, an arrival airport.
If you markup those properties
in the emails you send, then
we can show that as a
card in Gmail and in
Search and in Now.
We can also add buttons
to that, like
check-in if you want.
But another important thing here
is that Gmail will use
the markup you send us
to show the card.
But also, Gmail will update the
information for a flight
once we know that is a flight
with live data.
So you send us information about
a flight that leaves
tomorrow at 8:00.
If tomorrow we realize that the
flight is delayed, Gmail
will know that.
And when you open the card,
you will see the live
information.
It will say that the flight
is delayed tonight.
And same thing, we'll do the
other properties, like Google
[INAUDIBLE] will do.
So we have these four types
of actions in flights.
And you might have recognized
some names in the slides that
I showed you.
That's because today, we're
launching with many partners.
We've been working with partners
in the past few weeks
and months.
And today, we're very happy to
have many, many partners ready
to support this technology.
You probably know and use
some of these products.
Some of these names are here
at Google I/O, and would be
very happy to talk about their
integration and their
experience with this.
They are upstairs in the third
floor in the Chrome & Apps
sandbox area.
And after this talk, Shalini
and I, the rest of the team
and the partners that are here,
we'll all be upstairs
for you to talk about this.
So if you want to know more
about this, please join us
right after this in the Chrome
& Apps sandbox area.
So, OK, you know about
what you can do.
You've seen what other
people have done.
You might wonder, how
do I join this?
How do I do this myself?
Well, first of all, there is
the documentation we're
launching right now.
It's probably live already.
And that documentation is
at developers.googl
e.com/gmail/schemas.
So you can go there and find
all documentation about all
the types we support,
all the actions.
There are examples.
There are tutorials, anything
you need to get started now.
And I want to stress this.
You can start now.
Because when you go home
tonight, you can test these
yourself by sending emails
with markup to yourself.
This is a very, very easy
way for you to test it.
So we care about user
experience.
So we need to make sure that
what lands into production,
what lands into everyone's
inbox is safe.
But if you want to test it
yourself, you can just send
emails to yourself.
And those will be processed
and rendered.
So you have an immediate,
easy way to test it now.
Once you test everything and
you have a compelling use
case, and you want to launch
this to production, please go
back to developers.googl
e.com/gmail/schemas.
There is a page where
you can sign up.
At that page, you will find a
forum where you can tell us
about your use case.
And you can tell us about how
that work and what the
advantage the user have.
Because what we want here is
not just to add buttons
everywhere.
Because that doesn't really
help the users.
What we want here is to add
exciting use cases, exciting
features, better ways
for your users to do
stuff inside Gmail.
So please get back to us.
And we promise to review your
application and get back to
you as soon as possible.
We promise to be very quick.
So everything is at
developers.googl
e.com/gmail/schemas.
And with that, I think
that's it.
We showed you everything we
wanted you to know about this
for this launch.
I just want to remind you that
we're going to be upstairs
after this talk, the whole team
is going to be there.
But we still got 10 minutes
for questions.
So Shalini and I
would be really
happy to get your questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Do
we need microphones?
Can you step to the
microphone?
I think it's going
to be recorded.
It's actually Livestreamed.
Hey, mom.
AUDIENCE: So we have a service
that sends out event
recommendations to people, but
we've tried really hard to
make sure we don't overwhelm
people's inbox by bunching
those all together so
you get five or six
recommendations in one email.
Can we have more than one action
associated with an
email, or do we need to send
a single email for a single
entity that can have an
action against it?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So right
now, what we're going to
launch is a single action,
but that can be related
to a group of things.
So the action, the single
call to action is
unique, one per email.
But the entity can be actually
a group of entities, or
multiple things.
Of course, the action then has
to either refer to one of them
or to all of them as a group.
AUDIENCE: You showed some
interesting examples of cards
that sound like they're mapping
to specific actions,
like rating or RSVPing.
What is the capacity for more
free-form customization to
build sort of our own more
customized type of forms that
may be presented
in that format?
SHALINI AGARWAL: So over
time, we'll be adding
more types of actions.
But right now, there's not--
the customization lies within
the box that you saw in terms
of for RSVP, can you say
yes, or no, or maybe?
Or what are the options?
And the reason for that is that
we want to make sure that
we provide a consistent
user experience.
Because if we allowed the UI to
be completely customized,
every email would
look different.
Every box would look
different.
And it would, again, be
difficult for users to figure
out what to do and
get things done.
But we definitely want to hear
about your use cases because
we do want to add more
types of actions.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I think the
bottom line there is that we
want to add more actions, and
we want to talk to you about
them, what you actually need.
But we need to find a fine
line between adding a new
auction and allowing everyone
to do anything.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
If outlook.com or Yahoo
Mail wanted to add
schemas, could they?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You mean,
add to their emails?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So you could actually do the
same kind of things.
So if I write one email with
schemas, then it would work in
Outlook and in Yahoo Mail?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So as I said,
this technology is open.
And we actually would like
them to support this.
AUDIENCE: So it is open?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Yeah, it is open.
It's based on schema.org.
And we are in talk with
some other companies.
So some other big names know
about this already.
And then, of course,
it's up to them to
implement it or not.
AUDIENCE: Of course.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: But
yeah, it's open.
That's a short answer.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What other applications, other
than Gmail, will these actions
become available in within the
Google product offerings?
For instance, Voice--
will it tie-in with
Google Voice.
Obviously, Google Now has access
to that information.
Are there other places we should
look for to be able to
[? provide ?]
cards?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So right now,
this schema is supported
by Gmail, Search, and Now.
And not all of them support
the same entities
and the same actions.
So the first step for us would
be to have all of them support
the same entities and
same actions.
Of course, if that makes
sense for each client.
Another Google property that
uses schema is Google+.
So we're also standardizing
the entities we support
together with the
Google+ team.
And we realize that schema helps
the web, helps other
properties.
So we're adding schema support
to properties that you know.
That makes sense.
So far, we have identified
these four.
So Gmail, Search, Now, and +.
But if it makes sense for other
properties to support
schema, we'll be really
happy to do it.
And everyone at Google
will be.
AUDIENCE: I guess my
for-instance would be the
ability for not only Gmail to
be able to show a card, but
for other applications within
Google to be able to take the
same action.
I understand the schemas
generally could
be parsed by anything.
But from an action execution
standpoint, you're saying
that's still underway
or not necessary?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah,
it's underway.
We're definitely thinking about
adding actions to other
properties.
One, let's say, implementation
detail, is that we have--
we share the parsing technology
at Google, of course.
So it's easier for other
properties to use.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
In your example, say, where
you reviewed a restaurant.
And at the end of it, you're
done, but the email's still in
your inbox.
Is that going to be archived
automatically at some point.?
SHALINI AGARWAL: So right now
what happens is that once you
complete the action, the email
is marked as read.
We do not auto archive the
email at the moment.
If we see that as a strong
user request,
we'll think about it.
But right now as we roll this
out, we want to be sure that
users understand what's
happening.
So that's not going to
happen right now.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I saw screenshots of the
list view and I saw
card in a body view.
But do the other buttons
appear in the
body view as well?
So for example, like
do the review?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You mean
when the email is open?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SHALINI AGARWAL: So all in-app
actions will appear in the
body view as well.
So the one-click action
will appear.
And rate and review has the
nice card, just like the
flights does.
RSVP has a nice card, just
like the flights does.
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Thanks.
Sorry, one other question.
The goto action button, building
on the previous
question, does it show
completed, even if you have to
go to an external website
to complete the action?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: The goto
action doesn't really have a
completed state.
So it doesn't really change.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
For the developers that are
building on top of Gmail, like
third-party clients, how can we
make sure that these emails
are actually useful
to the user?
And do you have any help for
the developers to implement
the same type of actions
depending on the schemas?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Well, one
thing is that the vocabulary,
the schema is public.
So in the documentation,
we explicitly say
which types we support.
And all the additions we added,
like all the new things
we added to the schema, are
being added to schema.org so
the public vocabulary, Or at
least are being considered by
schema.org.
On a third-party side to support
this only takes--
well, what it takes is
constructing the markup and
supporting those
specific types.
Then, the rendering--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, do you have any
specific guidelines for
how it should be rendered and
how it should behave?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I would
say not really.
Because what we want is that
the user interface is
consistent within the client.
So for Gmail, of course,
we know how
that should look like.
But another client, like the
same drop down we use for
Gmail might not be
the best UI.
So we will not ask you to
implement any specific UI.
And the only recommendation,
which is like a standard
recommendation, is to make sure
that that provides the
best user experience
and matches the
consistent user interface.
AUDIENCE: If we have
like any--
is there a developer support
group that we can talk from
the client side, not from
the sender side?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You
mean as a user
that gets these actions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, for the third-party
developers who are building
email clients on top of Gmail.
How can we get help from you?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So we
have a page in the docs
that also says that.
But as we're doing with many
other products at Google, we
decided to support developers
where they already are, which
is Stack Overflow.
So we are there.
And another thing that I always
advise is-- that is my
Google+ handle.
Reach out to me directly.
I'll be really happy
to talk to you--
all developers.
And I'll point you to the
correct resource.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: This is a
quick question.
I was just wondering if you guys
are looking at bringing
this to the mobile interfaces.
So these actions on iOS
and the Android apps?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Yeah.
So we are working on mobile
as well, but it'll
take time to get out.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SHALINI AGARWAL: I agree that
it's very useful on mobile.
AUDIENCE: How do you manage the
authentication because all
the action comes in the
email that can be
forwarded or anything.
How do you identify that the
email you sent is-- the action
is completed by the
person that you
intended to do the action?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So we require
emails to be signed
[INAUDIBLE].
To be signed so that we know who
the sender is and we can
guarantee that the sender is who
the sender pretends to be
or says he is.
And at launch, what we're doing
right now is that we
have a white list.
So you, as a developer, in order
for your markup to be
showed to all users, will have
to be added to the white list.
So we will have you to
talk to us, tell us
about your use case.
Show us what you'll do.
We'll add you to
the white list.
Then we know who you are.
You sign your emails and that
proves that you are who you
say you are.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Just one other question.
Are you considering more complex
actions, like a kind
of rating, but for e-commerce?
When you write that you bought
something, but in the action
maybe you are confirming that
you bought that item and that
causes a charge to be billed
to the seller.
And sometimes you can write
positive only if
you bought the item.
Some logic inside the action,
are you considering
[INAUDIBLE]?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Not at
this moment I would say.
But yeah, that's another
use case we would
like to talk about.
Let's talk about it later
if you're still around.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Sort of related to the
last two questions about
lack of mobile and another
need for degradation.
If the recipient is not in a
supported mode or the sender's
not authenticated, is the
degradation just that the
actions don't show?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
So essentially we're
just being ignored.
AUDIENCE: And then another
question is, does that affect
the SMTP envelope
contents at all?
For like enterprise use, none
of this is going to be
archived as part of the
email itself, right?
Or yes?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Doesn't
affect anything?
It's part of the HTML body.
So it's extra markup
in the HTML body.
Unless there's some other part
where that is stripped, or
prevented, or blocked,
or anything.
We don't do anything
to prevent that.
It shouldn't affect it.
SHALINI AGARWAL: It should get
delivered like any other
message at that point.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Recently, you added
a feature in Gmail where you
can add to Calendar.
Does that use you schemas?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So there
are two things there.
The Add to Calendar or the
integration with Calendar that
you saw today and you will
see in the next days
are based on schema.
That part also uses some
intelligence data.
I mean, I think what you're
talking about is the feature
where Gmail, in the sense you're
talking about a date or
an event, right?
So that is actually based on
some other machine learning
things where we try to
understand that that email is
about an event invitation--
AUDIENCE: Got you.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
If we get that.
Because that is not really
in the email.
That can be triggered by me
sending an email to you with
no markup and saying, hey, can
we go have a beer tomorrow?
AUDIENCE: That's
what I thought.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So yeah,
Gmail will understand that
with machine learning
technology.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank you.
SHALINI AGARWAL: Great.
I think we have another
question.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
There's Gmail Gadgets.
I was wondering if you were
thinking of, in the future of
implementing a way
to launch a Gmail
Gadget from these actions?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I
don't think we have
any plans to do that.
SHALINI AGARWAL: You're talking
about the gadgets on
the right-hand side of Gmail?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Sidebar
gadgets or contextual gadgets?
AUDIENCE: No, the
Gmail Gadget.
There's both.
There's the full pain view
that you can get and then
there's also sidebar gadgets.
I was wondering if there
was a way to interact?
SHALINI AGARWAL: Right now
there's no plans to do that.
But tell us about what you'd
like to do and we can always--
AUDIENCE: Widgets, sorry.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, OK.
Yeah, no plans.
If there is a specific use case
you have in mind, let us
know, please.
Thank you.
SHALINI AGARWAL: All right,
I think we're out of time.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]